quand je t'ai trouvée j'ai décelé en toi
une puissance brute est intenté et au
delà de ça autre chose de tout à fait
exceptionnel vu une pub laser
[Musique]
je l'avais senti une telle énergie à
l'état brut qu'une seule fois je n'en
avais pas eu assez peur alors
[Musique]
aujourd'hui mes frais
moi au contraire la matière honnêtement
le prends pas mal mais je crois que
cyril préféré une chroniqueuse un peu
plus jeunes un peu plus fraîches et je
pense qu'il a raison
[Musique]
oh
nous sommes l'état sem
ça ne se passera pas
tu crois
il est temps
hop lire
n'est ce pas
où est la place pour tout ça bah c'est
toi que tu es noir va bien se passer le
paquet
[Musique]
mais